this is not clickbait this is this is
real stuff this video will may not be
online forever and i mean that for real
we have past experience with Valda Mork
taking our videos down so just FYI if
you see this video and you want to watch
it watch it while you still can
okay you may not be able to watch it
forever now recently I was accused of
cyberbullying autumn work which is
absolutely ridiculous because as you can
see this is a no bullying zone okay on
coffee Zillah we don't bully anybody I
would never do that and in fact if
you're in the comment section bullying
someone else I will bully you until you
stop so when I was reported to YouTube
to Twitter to Instagram because I was
cyberbullying volta Morton I said I got
to talk about this I got to tell the
people what's going on
so why who is volta Mort well I reported
on this guru and basically he took down
my video that was demonstrating that he
copies other people's content because he
said I used his name and so this person
is now referred to as Baltimore on this
channel because we can't mention his
name now as a reminder for why I had
called out Baltimore because I think
that's kind of relevant so I caught him
out for copying other gurus content
because I can almost guarantee that if
you have a state of fear like I'd almost
guarantee you that if you are in a state
of fear it's because you're focusing on
certain things that are making you feel
that way then you're focusing on the
things that actually put you into that
state and to be fair he made a response
video the last thing that really grinds
my gears is a few Pizza roll eating
cheesy poof dust covered haters they're
just cheesy poof dust handed people you
know these people are just little
keyboard warriors who have the pure
nerve to claim that me Kevin David and
other youtubers copy each other's
content and ideas blasphemous basically
volta mort's defense for his plagiarism
boils down to well everybody else is
doing it so it's totally fine if I do it
but as a refresher no that's actually
not true
because while other people may get
inspired by somebody else's content and
make a video that's similar the
substance of the video itself is almost
always different this is very different
from Baltimore and what he was actually
accused of my problem with
He Who Shall Not Be Named is that he
doesn't just copy a thumbnail he copies
the actual ideas in the video he copies
the actual substance and structure of
the video as if he almost like copy and
pasted it directly into his script today
I want to show you tonight
age of twenty seven twenty seven enjoy
the journey to enjoy the process you get
that says a journey he copies their
actual video which is what I have a
whole problem with especially without
attribution like here like no where does
Valda Mort say that he's getting his
ideas from Tai Lopez Sears is going
bankrupt their Sears is bankrupt
American Apparel went bankrupt
American Apparel bankrupt JCPenney will
be gone JCPenney gone Walmart's on the
decline
Walmart's on the decline and I never met
a millionaire of my life I had never met
a millionaire in my entire life let me
remind you guys what plagiarism is
plagiarism is the copying of another's
ideas words or writing and pretending
that they're one's own work so anywhere
on Baltimore's video do you see hey this
video was copied from blah blah blah No
and actually it's interesting you can
find out Baltimore's whole style of how
he does this in another video where he
shares what he thinks is fair game in
copying of what he thinks is stealing
I'm not saying you should go out and
literally copy them exactly but what you
can do is you can copy and paste parts
of things that you like copy and pasting
parts of what you like without
attribution is plagiarism and then you
can just rewrite that content so it's
your own what rewriting it so it's your
own does not keep you from plagiarism
right like twisting the words a little
bit doesn't all of a sudden make it not
plagiarism right you don't want to just
steal other people's answers and things
like that but you can copy and paste
specific sections and things from all
the different answers that you find that
you like that's one of the definitions
of plagiarism this is called mosaic
plagiarism it's in the wiki page is when
parts of others works are copied without
using quotation marks
it can also be when the student keeps
the same structure and meaning of an
original passage and only uses synonyms
kind of like
this maybe you want to retire at the age
of 45 55 65 you know maybe you're 40 50
60 70 years old but what I do know is
but what I do know it's possible it's
possible so I thought that that whole
defense was pretty weak but that's not
why you came here guys I was just keep
getting up to speed on everything that
had happened you'd get the idea from
watching him but he doesn't think about
coffee Zillah he's not worried about
coffee so he said he's a boss you
probably know by now that I never ever
respond to haters because life is short
he doesn't have time for hater II but
thanks to a coffee Zilla insider who
came forward brave man and submitting
these screenshots from inside of one of
Voldemort's own Facebook groups we can
actually see a much different picture of
what's going on where my channel is
being falsely flagged by this person in
order to get it shut down for no reason
for just invented reasons right so check
this out so so after saying that he
doesn't focus on the negativity there's
a whole facebook chat look at this look
at this I will go through this slowly
and I'm gonna blur the name of anyone
who is not Baltimore so that you know
because Baltimore is a public figure you
know very well known in the JK rowling
franchise while these people are not so
I'm going to blur out the names that are
not Baltimore downvote him too but don't
give him any extra views thank you this
one too and it's one of my videos again
this is a private facebook chat thank
you everybody
then from this other person this video
too please report their reporting my
videos for what we'll find out doing now
done and then all volta Mort himself
saying Cowabunga cowabunga guys cala
bunga Dunn also reported his Instagram
account there's also a post regarding KD
there and then they post my Twitter
account which is a screenshot my own
personal screenshot that YouTube sent me
okay and then they want to report my
Twitter as well for what I mean that's
my screenshot it's not copyright so
they're gonna falsely flag me for
copyright on my Twitter with my content
okay this is the kind of false lagging
behavior you find look these guys
portray themselves as bosses behind the
scenes they're so thin-skinned man like
this and then we have Baltimore himself
coming in so that he can't claim that he
had no part in this he says yeah let's
do an infringement report for IG as well
this other guy says yeah let's report
his Twitter - here's the Baltimore
smoking gun right here already did so so
let me get this straight
let me get this straight real quick okay
you're gonna make a little video where
where you brush off criticisms you know
you're gonna pretend like oh I don't
respond to these people I don't I don't
who coffee Zilla who what whose coffee
Zilla exit except behind the scenes
you're having your whole team your old
game report me you're reporting me for
what for what I mean you have no reason
or your false flagging my channel my
Twitter my Instagram for talking about
you like it blows my mind
I guess as soon as you get a million
dollars you become a douchebag who
thinks oh nobody can talk about me
without me reporting them nobody can say
anything bad about me nobody how dare
you how dare you say anything bad about
me I'm gonna report you I'm gonna have
my team report you look at this I don't
have Twitter or I'd report him there to
Baltimore Tagen Instagram what is he
doing using trademark and our content I
assumed first of all I did not second of
all if I had it would have been fair use
but what I actually put there was just
my copyright infringement that I got so
how is that your content how is that
something you can report me over you
can't so this is a false flagging
operation by Baltimore to try to get
criticism taken down off of YouTube
Instagram and Twitter guys I want you to
understand these people they can't
handle the truth right like they're
gonna say oh yeah whoo hoo coffee Zilla
whoo you know oh just the haters just
the cheesy puffs handed haters you know
but in the meantime while I'm sleeping I
don't know I had no idea this was going
on I was just chilling making content on
future gurus because there's
many people full of it on the internet
right now this person is behind the
scenes trying to get my channel falsely
flagged so we continue same post on his
YouTube channel to the Unruh reporting
is Twitter account to Baltimore says
thank you
you know you say one thing criticizing
these people no no no you're gonna get
reported does everyone know how to
report a YouTube video on YouTube I
chose to say this but feel free to
change it as we don't all say the same
thing pass it on to others to others
that I've missed so then they set up a
template for reporting me and say hey
guys we don't want to appear like we're
false flagging this guy and making up
you know just copy pasting the same
reason over and over we want to pretend
like this is a genuine you know this
isn't just astroturf we want to pretend
like it's just a bunch of individuals
and not just our organization so we're
gonna change the same we don't want to
all say the same thing then we have
Baltimore it's saying yeah report and
then choose hateful or abusive content
then bullying and then we have Altamont
once again asking hey guys did everyone
report it for hateful content or abusive
content then bullying please reply yes
you did we want to make sure to try to
get it removed truly guys we live in a
clown a world where these gurus expect
to be able to copy content sell shady
courses and then have no retribution and
if anyone dares to criticize the heirs
to exercise their right of free speech
to talk talk about them hey that's
bullying
[Music]
[Music]